[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
wednesday september 14th i'm zoe thomas
for the wall street journal
on tuesday the senate judiciary
committee heard from the twitter
whistleblower peter zadko
zatko became the company's head of
security in 2020 after a high profile
hack but was fired this past january
the company says it was for ineffective
leadership and poor performance
zatko says his termination came after he
clashed with executives over his
concerns the company was failing to
protect users data privacy
and now he's detailed those accusations
to congress
because twitter leadership is misleading
the public
lawmakers
regulators and even its own board of
directors
what i discovered when i joined twitter
was that this enormously influential
company was over a decade behind
industry security standards twitter has
dismissed zatko's claims and said his
whistleblower complaint is filled with
inaccuracies the accusations come though
as twitter is preparing to fight elon
musk in court to force him to go through
with his 44 billion dollar purchase of
the company
so what did we learn from the testimony
about user privacy and twitter's future
joining us to discuss this is wsj tech
reporter alexa course
hi alexa thanks for being here thanks
for having me
so alexa let's jump into some of the
testimony obviously we know twitter has
a lot of data about its users why did
that go say this was such an issue yeah
well i mean
like a lot of social media platforms
twitter is gonna have you know
information about its users and zacco's
concern is that he says too many
engineers at the company have too much
access to all this data and he's worried
that with all that access someone could
potentially use it for you know
nefarious purposes
some of those nefarious purposes that he
was talking about he says there may be
multiple foreign agents working at
twitter i just want to play this clip
from zadko he's responding to a question
from iowa senator chuck grassley i and
many others had recognizing the state of
the environment at twitter
we're really thinking if you are not
placing foreign agents inside twitter
because it's very difficult to detect
them
it is very valuable to a forward agent
to be inside there as a foreign
intelligence company you're most likely
not doing your job
where was he claiming these agents were
coming from and what were they doing
inside of twitter
right zacco says this is a big concern
of his and he says he spoke with other
people about twitter
about suspicions that foreign agents
could be working there
you know he mentions one example concern
about a potential chinese government
agent
and actually there's a previous case
that we already knew about where a
former twitter employee was convicted of
spying for saudi arabia
so that's where these concerns are
coming from
i want to play another moment from the
hearing because to me this got to the
scale of the problem this is an exchange
between zatko and senator mike lee of
utah who starts by asking a question
about one of the claims we've heard that
twitter can't remove user data even if
the user deletes their account we'll
hear from senator lee first what do they
mean by when they refer to the inability
to delete data what why is that
significant if you don't know where your
data is as we talked about these large
amounts of data and somebody comes in
and says i've left the system you know
and maybe the ftc asks well you know
have you deleted all the user data um
you can't
respond in the affirmative because even
if you've deleted the account correct
because you don't know where else this
data lives in systems because you don't
know what data you have and where it is
that's correct so does this mean that
twitter is actually unable
to delete data or is it just unwilling
um it is unable because they do not know
where it is so they are unable to comply
this isn't the first time twitter has
been accused of mishandling data is it
yeah well i mean you know twitter is
disputing this but this is what we're
hearing from the whistleblower and you
know we do know twitter has gotten in
hot water with federal regulators before
and even earlier this year the ftc said
twitter had violated a previous
agreement about how they should be
handling users information and so
twitter said it would pay a 150 million
dollar penalty so this was all
definitely like a backdrop to the
hearing yesterday and the concerns the
whistleblower is raising
has twitter responded at all to this
testimony yeah twitter has broadly
denied these allegations and on tuesday
a company spokeswoman said the hearing
only confirms that mr zakka's
allegations are full of inconsistencies
and inaccuracies
the spokeswoman said twitter's hiring
process is independent of any foreign
interference
and a company spokeswoman also said that
the company manages access to data
through measures including background
checks access controls and monitoring
systems
do we expect to see somebody from
twitter testify before congress next
so senator chuck grassley said the
committee had invited twitter's ceo to
speak but that he rejected the
invitation and said he wasn't able to
speak while twitter was still dealing
with litigation with elon musk over a
potential takeover but the senator you
know said he wants to investigate this
issue further and that this hearing is
just the first step
so we'll see you know if they try to
invite the ceo again
senator amy klobuchar brought up some
issues about privacy legislation that
she's been working on that other
senators have been working on do we
think this hearing this whistleblower
complaint will move the needle at all in
terms of getting legislation passed
yeah we heard senators talking about
wanting to pass new legislation i
thought it was really interesting when
we heard senator lindsey graham a
republican say he wanted to work with
democrats on some new regulation of
course it's hard to pass big legislation
so you know i can't predict
what's next
but this is giving momentum to lawmakers
who've been wanting to pass some new
legislation around social media
companies this obviously isn't the only
thing that twitter is paying attention
to it's shareholders approved the 44
billion takeover by elon musk which they
are fighting him over in court
how do we think the testimony and you
know the whistleblower complaint at
large is going to affect that case going
forward that's one of the big questions
you know one difference is that musk has
really focused on his concerns about
bots and spam but that actually wasn't
you know a focus of the senators but we
do know that musk got permission to
amend his complaint to include some of
the whistleblowers claims so we'll have
to see how that plays out going forward
all right that's our reporter alexa
course thanks so much for joining us
alexa thanks for having me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]
you